my name is gigi bustamante i
am married to andrew bustamante we were
both
cia officers that's where we met we
met on orientation day basically so
we met i think i i noticed him
after the first week and he was always
uh seated between
two females but i decided yeah
i saw him from a distance and i was like
i'm going to meet that guy
and so it took me about three weeks to
get a seat next to him and start up a
conversation
and he was great as soon as i introduced
myself he was like
do you want to go out on a date
wednesday i was like yes yes i would wow
very much yeah it was great so um the
bummer for him was i was
dealing with um an anxiety disorder at
the time that had just kind of
i'd had it for about six months
undiagnosed um so i was having all this
anxiety constantly and it was making me
really physically ill
and um so he asked me out on the date
the night of the day
he called me to ask directions to my
house and i was like
i was throwing up i was like
i was like i can't go he's like are you
sh like
do you want coffee instead do you want
he kept trying trying you know
and i'm like i just can't and that was
the very end of our orientation i was
like i can never
see this guy again like he makes me
throw up
i have too much anxiety i like him too
much i was like
this sucks like i'm never going to see
him again so then we spent
like i think an a month working on the
same floor
in our offices completely avoiding each
other
until i bumped into him at a staff
meeting and then i was like
how old were you i was 27. wow
yeah yeah it was intense and i was
it he was a very patient man because we
had a lot of tea dates
when i was like i'm really nauseous
right now like you make me so nervous
no no this like it parlayed into you
guys
eventually working together like right
as a team yes and that was that like
before
you guys got like into a relationship
relationship or was it the relationship
first and then you guys teamed up
together
so it was the relationship first and um
you know part of what brings us together
um are our commonalities so we both have
an interest in a background in asia
and that's the region that we were
working so we were in different offices
but the same region and so we both had
um so i was i lived in japan from the
ages of two to six
and i spoke japanese when we lived there
and then we moved back to the states
after that
so i had this you know my like hit my
like pivotal
my growing years were in japan so i had
this
yeah so i had this really strange in
japan
my parents my
my dad's venezuelan so my mom met
my dad in fort lauderdale moved with him
to venezuela i was born there and they'd
converted to buddhism
a buddhism that the sect is um it's
the nichiren uh nietzsiding shoshu
buddhism and
from japan so they had friends who had
already gone
to like explore this buddhism more in
japan
and my parents were trying to figure out
how to get there my dad
found the school that did had a masters
in architectural photography
so he enrolled in the school he like
learned japanese
enrolled in architectural photography
school and
they just took us well i was just me at
the time so yeah my mom i'm two
and my mom goes halfway across the world
and
they like adventure that's super cool
yeah you learned
english and japanese i mean you were
obviously old enough to already know
english but you learned japanese at a
very young age
yes so japanese spanish and english were
my first three languages
which was interesting when i moved back
because i moved to st
petersburg and um my second grade
teacher
tried to hold me in my first grade my
first grade teacher tried to hold me
back
because she said that knowing so many
languages made me slow
which you know that's it was 1986.
that's okay um but my mom pushed back
and i ended up in gifted class instead
so
um teach their own exactly but ever
since then i was
you know when we got to the agency
you know i i want i had spanish i was
like i can pick japanese right back up i
had enough of it
and that was my interest and then andy
has chinese
and his um he has a degree in east asian
studies
and so we had this common interest in
that region
and in working the targets in that
region so it
was natural for us to eventually
end up working the same targets i don't
think we were ever
at the same time in the same office but
that doesn't mean that
we weren't working the same targets if
that makes sense like um
for example they'll have a regional
office that will do asia
but then they'll have another office
that does a subject matter like counter
proliferation
right so you can be have two people one
in a regional office one in counter
proliferation and then they overlap
because counter proliferation happens
everywhere in the world so that's how it
ended up happening
and where are you guys at at this point
like where is the cia headquarters
like that you guys where's the building
that you guys are working at so we were
in langley at the main
headquarters yeah okay yeah and we were
there for
quite some time before and you know
doing tdys and things like that
so and how long was it before you guys
actually went out into the field
and went to asia together so we and
where'd you guys go to china
uh we i yeah we can't say the exact
location
asia um
but we did a number of tdys
separately um so we had started
traveling for the agency
almost as soon as we joined oh okay
right like
him going you know i would go one
country he would go another country
at different times as the office as the
mission dictated
um and then eventually i
i knew that i wanted to be assigned
overseas
um for a longer period of time so i
started you know
just putting a little bug in my
manager's ear like i will go
literally anywhere um i was like
oolambatar
i don't care like just send me overseas
um
i wanted the excitement of being in the
field because it's the work is different
right like headquarters work is
slower field work like you are on the
ground
real time like stuff happens you know
like um
where we were there was a like a small
terrorist attack while we were assigned
there
you know i'm like it's action like stuff
is happening real time like i'm working
with the foreign service there um
you know it's just incredible so we i
think we were
together
i think we were together three years um
before we were sent out for a long
assignment
and that was it was amazing do you think
because
because of your guys opposite
personality traits
do you think that made you guys work
better together yeah because a lot of
people there's a lot of
a lot of different opinions out there of
people who think that the same
personality types are better together
versus opposite personality types i'm
on i personally believe that opposite
personalities
fit together better because like you and
andy my wife and i
are completely opposite yeah so
um i think professionally
being opposites on the same team on the
same operation
was awesome like because we totally
filled in
each other's you know strengths and
weaknesses
personally that makes it a lot harder i
think i look at some couples that are
almost identical in personality and they
just seem to gel
and like everything's always smooth
like why can't i have that um
so yeah professionally i absolutely
think you know you have to have people
with different characteristics different
strengths weaknesses traits and that
really worked out for us
at the agency but at home it's
definitely much more of a struggle
trying to keep balance
and i don't know if it's just because at
home is like 24 7. where you know in an
op you get together you play in the up
everybody
does their part you know but at home
it's a little bit messier
[Laughter]
foreign